أعتقد أن هناك عددًا كبيرًا جدًا من المجالات
ذات الاهتمام المشترك والقيم المشتركة
بين الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية حتى لا
تفكر في أن هذا
الحادث المؤسف والمأساوي في تركيا
كان سيشكل اضطرابًا كبيرًا لمثل هذه
العلاقة التاريخية القوية.
شكوك في أن
ولي العهد كان متورطًا في هذا الأمر في نهاية المطاف ،
لذا حتى بالنسبة للعلامة التجارية للمملكة
العربية السعودية وسمعته في المستقبل ،
فإن ولي العهد هو زعيم عالمي على
المسرح العالمي ، فقد رأينا أنه في نهاية
مجموعة العشرين ، لذا فإن علامته التجارية
سمي قيادته جرأته وقدرته على
قيادة المملكة
لا تتزعزع ولن تتزعزع أبدًا في رأيي والأهم من
ذلك جون شعب المملكة
العربية السعودية يقفون بقوة وراء الملك سلمان
جلالته وولي العهد
وهم وراء القيادة
[موسيقى]